my name is Jane when linda and i am the
director of the science and engineering
libraries here at Columbia I have had
the privilege of working for libraries
here at Columbia for over four decades
now and have seen a variety of well it's
a varieties not the right term a massive
number of changes although some things
do stained the same and one of the
things that has remained relatively
stable is we got to have a plan I'm
going to read a couple of quotes here
after my colleagues introduce themselves
and see how they react to these quotes
that I hope will set off a lively
conversation so would you like to
introduce yourself please sure my name
is Miguel Figueroa I'm at the American
Library Association working on a future
of libraries project that we're terming
the center for the future of libraries
with thanks to IMLS for their support
and to the American alliance of museums
that started a center for the future of
museums that were arranging a lot of our
work around and mainly the three things
that I'm currently working on are
identifying trends that would be
relevant to libraries and the
communities that they serve extending
our conversation out to some external
partners and experts to encourage them
to dialogue with us about what the
future of libraries and librarianship
might be and then also to try and create
a space within our association that can
focus on innovation and foresight and
futuring techniques both for planning
tools and also for the improvement of
libraries hi I'm Elliott sure I'm the
executive director of the American the
American it's okay and it's not American
it's American and Canadian the
association of research libraries have
been in that role for two years and when
I was asked to take this on the first
thing that I was asked to do was to work
on a strategic plan and if we get to
that kind of a conversation the work
plan is a word I think as a as a
nineteenth and twentieth century word
not a 21st century word so we actually
thought about
a strategic thinking and design process
that has led to I think a lot of the
kinds of things that we're talking about
today so it's I'm sitting here thinking
about all of the things that we were
doing these past this past year that
that have been mentioned that are parts
of what we want to do and that that
planning process i'll use that term was
funded also by the IMLS and and melon so
so it's lovely to be able to to follow
that panel as we talk about how we got
there good afternoon I'm Deanna Markham
I'm the managing director of Ithaca S&R
which stands for strategies and research
our aim is to help the scholarly
ecosystem libraries publishers higher
education make the successful transition
to the digital environment one of the
articles that prompted my thinking is
from the July eighteenth 2014 issue of
The Chronicle of Higher Education and
the title of the article is how do you
plan the campus of the future ? try not
to and the article goes into quite a lot
of detail about Dan Hutton Locker Dean
Hutton lager is Cornell's tech school
new dean and if you've read a lot about
the tech school you know that it's
really based on I really not the right
person to talk about it but innovation
and change etc another article that i
found interesting it was the it's from
the january2014 issue of the Harvard
Business Review and it's called the big
lie of strategic planning and to quote a
couple of things from the article one
says it's a it's truly a terrible way to
make strategy meet referring to
strategic planning it may be an
excellent way to cope with fear of the
unknown but fear and discomfort or
essential parts of strategy making in
fact if you're entirely comfortable with
your
oh gee there's a song strong chance it
isn't very good true strategy is about
placing bets and making hard choices any
reactions to these two quotes yeah de
Quebec well you know I it's interesting
I think I I just had our board meeting
this week and the purpose of the board
meeting was to hear our three-year
strategic plan and so I spent a lot of
time on a strategic plan in recent days
and what it is is it's a way to
articulate your vision it's not the plan
really because you're right you have to
keep making changes and and things come
up and you have to adjust and move on
but it is a way to describe in simple
terms what the single vision is why does
this matter so you really move away from
strategy to where are we trying to go
and I think it's important to hold on to
some structure I don't really care what
we call it but some structure that
forces us to say in simple terms what it
is we're doing it why it matters and
it's also a way to bring other people in
the organization along with you it's so
important to have a structure for doing
that and it's a way for people to buy in
I was thinking about what um Josh and
Maura and Dom are just talking about
about software and an emulation and
trying to save it and what Joshua's
talking about was that one piece of
software is linked to another or you use
six or seven of them and we were
thinking about in our strategic thinking
design process that this is what one we
call a wicked problem I mean it's not
something that I think one of the
problems with strategic planning that I
think you were discussing before is a
classic American cultural way to do
things you break it down into 20
different parts you name all the
problems and you work on the one at
time which of course doesn't work
anymore and the other way that you work
on a wicked problem is you come up with
a magic solution like MOOCs and so what
we were trying to do was not go either
of those ways but but exactly what
Deanna was talking about we were trying
to say we're what do we want the library
of 2033 to be if we were to create that
vision and could we get there by doing a
number of different things that would
affect the ecosystem some at a high
level like at the collective collections
level and some of some very smaller
levels you know introducing a data
curation folks and so what what does
that look like how can you do that and
how that is isn't that a better way to
try this and to allow ourselves to fail
and to think about the library in all of
its various and different ways of being
inside the university as a partner with
other libraries outside the university
in the community that all the kinds of
things that we talked about today we
actually looked at all of the strategic
plans of every hundred and twenty and
every 125 libraries and all of their
universities to and when we can find
them the IT departments and the presses
those are much harder to find that was
the work that melon helped us think
about and found a numbing kind of
sameness in these plans and and we
actually ended up not looking at the
plans what they said all the time but
what they said only a few times and we
found that long tail those kinds of
things that sort of sit on the edges to
be much more interesting so I think we
need a vision and I need a we need a
flexible way to get there but it were
but what we're going to do in your one
year to and your three that's I think
the comforting part that doesn't work
yeah I think when I think strategic plan
it's it's that idea that we pick
something up at one point in time and we
write it all down and then we move
forward with it and it reminds me of one
of the the quotes that stayed with me is
the 21st century is a terrible time to
be
control freak and uh Alec Ross who was
the senior adviser to secretary of state
hillary clinton said this and i was in
an audience and it's just like that hit
me right in the core because I'm a
librarian and that I like control
freakiness but it all it it also reminds
me of those strategic plan ideas and in
some of the futuring theory that's out
there they talk about this there's
different views of the future there's
the expected future which is what
organizations kind of collectively
decide and view and they anticipate it
and futurists say that those almost
always fail and and that seems to
resonate sometimes with strategic
planning I think because it is what we
collectively agree upon and instead
there's this promotion of this idea of
alternative futures that there are
multiple futures that exist out there
and there's a cone of plausibility that
we can impose and kind of say from the
past and the present we can articulate
out and see some of the limits of
plausibility that could occur and a
range of futures that might be within
that space and I think that that's a
really important way to think and it
probably is the opposite of what
strategic planning is is because it's
actually identifying lots of different
realms and introducing lots of new
information i I don't have insight into
to how I MLS decided to do this but I
think that idea of those conversations
year after year it's this collection of
information continuing to expand and and
refine that cone of plausibility and
then the last way a lot of people talk
about futures is this idea of preferred
futures that you have a vision that we
prefer and then that we work to create
and I think this echoes the first two
presentations that we heard from Jim and
from Carol that it's transforming vision
into action that that's perhaps the most
important part rather than the planning
of a vision or a strategy could I had
something to that because the IMLS
funded us to do those kinds of
conversations around North America we
had about 400 people come and what we
didn't do was look for the lowest common
denominator we honored every voice and
we had an architect and designer I
thought well this was great but what are
we going to do with all these brilliant
ideas
and we actually literally had an
architect and designer named am
Pendleton Julian who built scaffolding
so we could actually honor all of those
voices and find the highest level of
symmetry and not the lowest common
denominator I think listening to our the
people who care about these things
really matter what level of staff in
your organization's participate in
formal planning process is it senior
level staff if it is how do you sell the
importance of a strategic plan to
someone who doesn't come to work every
day and ok what's the strategic plan say
I'm supposed to do today but rather it's
the vision thing I'm just interested in
how in your you know big organizations
here how you involve people who are
probably going to be here in the future
and how they buy into the strategic plan
and what their role is in the vision
creation you might be asking the wrong
people yes my huge staff of 15 no it's
not too hard to involve everybody a
toxic plan but I think really what
you're getting at is we've heard today I
don't I don't know how many times it
started with Jim's brilliant of talk
followed by Carol's turning ideas into
action and many other times we need
national attention to these issues and
the real problem with the strategic
planning exercises in local institutions
is that you're thinking only about what
you need to do and they become they
become like branding exercises almost
you know what is it that we do that's
different from other people how do we
distinguish ourselves how do we make our
mark and instead we need to be figuring
out what are the structures
we're bringing people together just
carol was just so right on saying we
need to talk about the hard problem so
we need to talk about them together but
we don't have the structures for doing
that so we end up building our own plans
and then we join initiatives that I
think Maura talked about the 20,000
everything seems to be twenty thousand
dollars we join those initiatives and
hand over that part of the problem to
these initiatives and yet our our job as
leaders is to link the people in our
organizations to those broader issues so
I that's what I'd like us to focus on
when we talk about planning is how do we
move outside our own institutions and
tackle the really hard problems like
digital preservation like collective
collections like storage so one of the
wicked problems that we thought we had
to face for example was this this
wonderful opening for open access the
OSTP memo and the work of spark and all
the people who worked around that
happening and in some ways was a
prototype for what we wanted to do which
was this is not a problem for libraries
this is a possibility for higher
education and the and the community and
we started a process which has gotten
stronger at ARL which is exactly along
the lines at the ennis talking about
working with other organizations not
just sort of thinking about how
organization works so we're working with
the AAU and the APL you on a project
called chair and we've attracted a
number of other partners we're
attracting partners from outside the the
continental United States and also other
entities and we're learning one of the
things we had to learn in this process
is held as an organization partner with
another organization and the other thing
that we've had to learn
is how can the collective I believe this
is right and maybe mark and correct me I
think there are 11,000 people who work
in ARL libraries something along those
lines and there is an enormous amount of
expertise among those 11 1000 folks is
there a way to marshal that expertise to
to to tackle these wicked problems
together because many of them and you
heard the last panel and everybody
talking about these problems are are
beyond one library we have organizations
like ARL who actually can do that and
that was the idea so so trying to get
people to do it is it's a it's a
different kind of a question it's
learning how to collaborate and learning
how to be a partner and then how do you
actually translate that into action so
that's that's those are the issues that
were we're struggling with right now and
where we're at the point of
transitioning the way the organization
actually conscience has been interesting
next six months for the ARL in this in
this arena um in who to involve how do
we explain the American Library
Association um so I didn't give me
enough time but as we embark on a
strategic plan for a la I think we of
course have a great resource of members
and supporters and partners that are
helping us with that strategic plan and
i think that's that's going incredibly
well but i think one of the the things
that we've introduced is a focus on on
this Harwood method that we're using for
community conversations and it really is
an opportunity to engage more people in
the conversation and to try and do it in
smaller groups your phrase the honor
every voice I think is really so
important because I think that that's
what we're trying to do as we go through
that process though and I've sat in on a
couple of the hardwood conversations
than different strategic groups I think
what's interesting is the way that we
all adhere to a certain jargon that
masks what perhaps some of our real
ambitions might be and we can't find we
use the same language again and again
and again instead of really pursuing for
in asking well what what are we really
after what what's our real interest
behind that and I think as we've as
we've gone through some of these
conversations and her different people
say it in different ways we've been able
to go from the basic to the more
advanced and try and see what that
higher-level want and desire might be
and I also think one of the ideas that I
usually promote when I go out and talk
to different groups as we're talking
about this future of libraries idea is
the MIT media labs principles I don't
know if you're familiar with that it's
easier to to research Joey Ito is is the
director of the MIT Media Lab and he's
articulated some principles for the
Media Lab which kind of looks at design
and technology and they're great videos
and conversations on it but one of the
key principles there's nine of them is
emerged over authority and it's don't
let authority or no or norms limit our
potential or creativity and my
understanding was that an earlier
version of that principle was the crowd
instead of the experts trying to find
ways to pull the wisdom from the crowds
instead of strictly relying on the
experts that have become well-versed in
the particular issue or who are steeped
in it to try and really go back to the
well and find what the crowd has to say
could I say just one more oh sure about
this because I really worry that we've
as a profession become much too
interested in consensus and spending so
much time making sure that everyone is
included when in fact we have to be
thinking about how do we give up some
things for the greater good and what
we're not good at is stepping back and
saying you know there are so many people
involved in this issue and we're part of
that and we have some things to say
about it but there are others we're
going to have to compromise we're going
to have to do some things differently
and I think it's right to honor every
voice but not every opinion will get
included in these things that we put
together it just it just can't happen
where where
it is a word do not risk and creativity
where do they fit into long-range
planning or is there such a thing as
long range planning is that a term from
the past is that term of the 80s
weakling sanding is better it's sort of
it goes along with what you were saying
if I don't know that I've ever seen the
strategic plan is we're not going to do
this and we did this and it didn't work
and therefore we're going to do this
being but if they sound more visionary
than straightforward necessarily I was
just I was thinking about what Miguel
was saying about being a librarian in
like control and I I think actually this
is a cultural issue that is harder for
this group than for other groups to to
allow for risk and creativity because I
think the only the only marker of doing
things well as doing it perfectly and I
and I think that that something that we
have to give up and it's very hard to
give up because i think it's baked into
the DNA of what we do and i'm just
thinking about the satan the share
project you know i'm thinking about sort
of the 20th century perfection of all of
our metadata scheme into one or two and
now we have has done said many of them
pick your own and the data that we're
putting together for share now we have
350,000 records that we've gathered in
the last few months and trying to make
sense of the metadata is really another
wicked problem so it seems to me we have
to try some things that aren't perfect
and we have to approximate things and I
think this is this goes to your point
about consensus and also talking to
ourselves I think the other thing we
need to do is remember that we're part
of a larger ecosystem in the case of
research libraries the higher education
ecosystem and this has to be something
we work out with faculty with students
with other administrators so that we
start to approximate answers that that
may not that may not be perfect
in an old-fashioned library sense of
perfection but are approximating where
we need to get to so the long-range
piece and the risk piece and the
creativity piece are things that I think
we like to think long range but I think
risking creativity are going to have to
play a role in that long range and I
don't know how that's going to work so
it's a really that's why i think we all
stopped when you asked that question
it's it's a good question but it's not a
simple one tan turn and it's a this is
where leadership become so incredibly
important a lot of leaders will say I I
want this organization to take risks and
we're going to celebrate failure and
learn from failure and but the as soon
as there's a problem it's a crisis so it
this is in the application of the plan
where you see creativity and innovation
um and it that's when the leader shows
by example that we're trying to learn
things from problems we encounter if we
aren't successful we admit it and start
over and this is where politics comes in
you know sometimes it's just not
politically smart to admit failure but
internally we can learn from those
things and actually figure out how to
take risks as an organization as an
organization excuse me I think the risk
and creativity question is probably one
of the things that drove me a little
crazy about how do you plan the campus
of the future and this was the second
time i had read this the first time and
the second time i had the same response
it's really easy to be creative and to
take risks when you have two billion
dollars in a blank slate it just makes
life a lot easier and and i talked to a
lot of libraries and they are frightened
i think of taking risk sometimes and i
know that few libraries are rich and and
most of them are very far from it at
sometimes though i think back to i
worked retail
through undergrad and even grad school
and i remember in in retail and even in
restaurants i see it still in chain
restaurants they would just drop
something in a test market and i remem
to work like the stockroom so we'd get
boxes and I'd open a box and I'd be like
what are we supposed to do with this but
they would throw it at us and just say
this is a test put it on the floor look
at it see how it goes etc and they were
making big plans with a relatively small
investment for for their market that's
what they were really trying to do and
it might fail when we put it on on the
sales floor and it might not go where
they want but inevitably a year and a
half later we'd see the big roll out of
that test and they had taken all of
those little failures that all those
test markets had put into it and created
a different product for a different time
that actually worked in that environment
and that was a successful environment
and I know that there are some libraries
who are very successful at finding ways
to do that small drop test and say let's
just test this here see how it works
learn from it and then move forward and
it's a smaller investment than the full
fledge risk that's the great thing about
digital technology because it allows us
to separate things and deliver services
just to one small group and see how it
goes and then broaden it I think that's
a great advantage we have today thank
you all very much anything else you
would like to say I I my experience has
been about planning for space and that's
one of the hardest things to do because
it isn't as if you can say okay this
didn't work so we'll just throw out this
furniture and get some new furniture and
we'll tear down those walls and this
sort of thing I mean that's much more
difficult and you try this time we're
going to get it right and rarely do we
and it's a a frustrating thing so that
hutton lockers talking about having
large empty rooms and that's really to
me an interesting way to approach his
billions of dollars of space this is not
going to put something in it that can be
reusable or redone shortly it's it's
easy to do if you've got all that money
in whatever
but it's much more difficult with ideas
and vision to make it change like that
what's with that is the notion you get
it right and you're done and I think
that's what's wrong with strategic
planning actually and that's why it is a
twentieth-century idea I think there
were moments when things were a little
less volatile librarians don't like to
be wrong that's correct and we should
probably admit to when we're talking
about space planning that often the
money for space comes from donors who
have really clear ideas about the kinds
of monuments they'd like to build so our
exactly where their name our challenge
is to take that that philanthropy and
goodwill and then work with the people
who are going to be using the space and
try to figure out what it is they need
to do their work not what would be
beautiful necessarily and those are
those are hard things to bring together
I think we should just you know
acknowledge that but I found that the
work Nancy freed Foster and other
anthropologists have been doing in
working with the people who will
actually be sitting in that space is
just invaluable do we have any questions
we do
okay but we haven't talked about the use
of data my camp is for better worse has
embraced predictive analytics which is
data-driven evidence-based was a
scientific objective right I think you
see my position here but what's left at
the waste side is imagination the what
if so my question is for the panel how
do you reconcile and balance data
analysis and projections for forecasting
with risk and creativity so I think that
I didn't know how much of that was meant
i rana CLE and how much wasn't but i
think that there's all kinds of data and
some of its qualitative and some of its
quantitative and i think often when we
say scientific we mean quantitative data
and I think that's why I describe this
as a wicked problem I think one of the
things we're learning and when things
that Christa was talking about in the
clear fellows program where we started
out with almost all you menace and now
it's a wonderful mix of social
scientists and scientists hard
scientists and humanists is when we get
them together in a room and have them
together for a week one of them raises
their hand says which one of us is a
humanist and which one is a social
signed I think if we start breaking if
we start moving across these barriers
and I've seen this many times in my own
life I'm a historian and I'd been with
hard scientists a lot we have a lot to
say to one another and it seems to me
these are not hard categories anymore
where you know creativity sits here a
certain kind of data-driven way of doing
you know evidence-based hard data driven
ways over here and there's a creative
touch a humanist place over there I
think that is also part of the 20th
century and that's also part of what we
need to get beyond that's what I think
the most creative kinds of strategic
thinking
season try to do we didn't just talk to
the heads of the library's although we
talked to the heads of most of the area
libraries we had faculty members we had
community members we had a wells we had
scientists humanists because i think the
real crowdsourcing brilliance is in
trying hard to put all of those ways of
thinking together it's very very
difficult and sometimes you know if the
fashion is a certain kind of data-driven
answer is the one that's going to be
accepted for political reasons on your
campus you might have to move to that
direction but i think our job is to show
some leadership and try to draw from all
of those spaces so that's why i think
about thank you i was struck Elliott by
the lack of what appears to be a
strategic plans coming from the IT
organizations and we had a little
laughter in the room but perhaps they've
moved past this more aggressively than
the libraries have um but it's oh well
on the website that you can't find it
that's right but but we spoke earlier
about library as infrastructure and
library as innovator and when we talk
about infrastructure and law and we
start to talk about some ways library as
utility or service provider writ large
so there are in fact some 20th century
and 19th century concepts that in fact
apply to infrastructure and can you
speak to the challenge that we have as
an organization that both has to embrace
large-scale infrastructure and
innovation and change agent and we're
past time so thanks Robert what did Don
say when he got that question at the end
it's I think if you were to if you were
to design a library today with the two
billion or a campus I don't know if
you'd have a library and IT organization
a press a museum and you name it a
digital humanity center and they're all
funded differently run by different
people report to different people and
never talk to one another so I actually
think that some of this problem is an
18th century double entry book
keeping problem that um if you think
about the library is centrally funded
the press has to make its money back and
the digital humanities center has to
live on grants until somebody takes it
you know until melon stops giving them
money and they have to become part of
the institution so it seems to me we
have a we have a deeper problem in
higher education this is not a library
problem I think this is a much bigger
problem you know where and you know I
came from a merged organization I worked
in a tiny little place where I was in
charge of all of these things and it was
actually more efficient is that possible
on a huge campus there are only been a
couple of examples of that but it seems
to me that the products of the major IT
organization need to be integrated into
what the library does and there are
different ways to go about that maybe
that's the next wicked problem but I
don't see these as separate from one
another okay well I want to thank you
all very much this is an awesome panel
thank you